how did we get to a point where we
treated other human beings as slaves and
and were okay with that when I when I
see the the make America great again
my comment is
do you do you do you accept that that
could possibly be construed as a racist
remark when was it ever great in America
for the African-American so if you're
making it great again it's not including
them our privilege has created blind
spots for us and maybe I haven't seen
what is really happening first off
America is the least racist nation in
the history of the world that is why
black people white people Asian people
and all sorts of other people still want
to come here you know that slavery was
the way of the world and the United
States in the last 200 plus years was
the country that really ended it quicker
than anybody else